So now we've got the full spectrum here. We can create objects, move them, and
see them sliding around in the world, which is great, because now, we can
actually throw missiles from one robot at another. The final missing piece,
however, to our grand scheme of world domination, is what to do once the
missile hits the other robot. Now, in our current set up, we receive no
information that a collision has occurred. But we only get back the positions
of the objects that the physics engine has adjusted. But fret not my children,
there is a solution. We're going to need to jump around between a few different
files and concepts, but once we're done you'll be able to allow each entity to
respond to a collision independent of other entities. Now the start of this
nice aside is a Box 2D function that allows us to define an onCollison callback
that when called is given two physics bodies that are touching.